how to separate yourself in a price
competitive market so I got a question
recently from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys tranced fury who wrote in
to say hi having great video and as i
you believed in the power of belief i
strive to bring that every day to help
separate me from the competition i run
into a roadblock as of late in my
industry two-way wireless technologies
is extremely price driven and
competitive with multiple brands and
e-commerce any tips on helping separate
yourself in a price competitive market
this is such a super-important question
I'm so glad you asked this and it's the
advice here is not just for people in
price competitive markets and for all
entrepreneurs because no matter what
industry you're in you are going to have
a lot of competition and if you have no
way to stand out if you have no way for
customers to remember you that they
can't differentiate between your company
and somebody else then the only decision
they're going to make their choice on is
price price is important to everybody
okay there aren't that many people go
and say I don't care about the price
whatever I'm going to pick whoever I'm
just going to pick randomly I don't care
about the price that's not that many
people okay price is important price is
always going to be important but it's
not always the only thing out there
people care about other things you just
haven't educated people about why you're
different and so they only make a
decision based on price so here's my
advice for you three strategies okay
number one is build a brand what the
heck is different about your company
versus everybody else you got to let me
know like you told me about believe
that's great so if your word is believed
and that's what you're promoting then
that's got to be everywhere on your
branding that's going to be on your
store it's going to be on your website
then people who believe in believe as
well will be all over you right they'll
wanna box me they'll be willing to pay
more for you if your word is quality and
that's what you want to focus on you
build a brand around quality then I know
that by buying from you I'm getting a
quality product you're making my life
easier and the people who will scrounge
around the
Internet to try to find you know one
cent cheaper on the product you don't
want those guys those aren't going to be
long-term loyal great customers for you
you want the customers who will come to
you because they know you provide
quality and you're making their lives
easier you're selling convenience you're
not just selling wireless technology
right so whatever it is that you believe
in whatever your one word is whatever
you're trying to build a movement around
create that brand to make it easier for
people who believe the same thing as you
do to buy from you then it makes it
easier to charge more get more repeat
business get more referrals
so number one is build a brand number
two is service if there isn't a lot of
difference between the products that you
sell you stand out through your service
here's a quick example I recently did a
video thanking my web server guy Edie
like why would I want to make a video
thanking my web host really web hosts
come on he's in the most brutal business
write the web web hosting business is
cutthroat
it's drive to the bottom people offering
free web hosting and I spend $500 a
month with Edie as my web post where I
could know I could get a cheaper other
places why do I do that he selling a
commodity item right the exact same
thing and get from other people I do
because of the service because I value
my time because I want to work with a
company that understands me and Edie I
know has got my back if my site has some
issue he's going to be up till 3:00 in
the morning whatever it takes solvent so
that's why I go with him and I recommend
people to him you go to bounce web you
can go check it out so you got to stand
on the service think about how can you
better serve with your customers how can
you be their friend how can you actually
care about your customers it may be a
strange concept to a lot of people but
when you do that and you serve them well
they're going to keep coming back to you
and pay more for that luxury of working
with you as well so number two good
service number three is repeat business
and this comes hand-in-hand with one and
two if you're building a brand you've
run a great service you're going to
repeat business but what you want to do
is reach out to your current customer
base people who are coming back
or Laurel to people who you've you know
recently added to your roster because
you're providing all this great service
and they love what you stand for think
about what else they need and think
about how else may be able to help them
if you're introducing a new product or
you know that they're having problems in
certain areas you can help solve that
problem with one of your products and
again here's an example from edy my
server guy he was launching an automatic
backup plan where we automatically
backup all my data on my website and
something I didn't want to do manually
and he knew that my data was important
to me and so he reached out and said hey
here's something I'm launching I think
it might be a good fit for what you're
trying to do and it's not a sales pitch
right it's not a sales pitch to me
because edie knows me and he cares about
me and I'm feeling the love when it
reaches out to offer this sink to me and
I think about it yeah I could use that
Edie
here's my credit card sign me up and so
it doesn't rely on me coming back to his
website and looking at what his new
product offerings are he is reaching out
to me because he has something new that
he thinks can help me and so what you
want to do to your customer base as well
if they love you if they feel that you
care about them if you reach out to them
with a new product a new offering that
you think will help them based on what
you know about them and what they bought
in the past then it's actually a service
to them right and they're going to open
up their credit cards give it to you and
say go for it so repeat business so in
summary if you're trying to stand out in
a price competitive market number one
build the brand number two service
number three repeat business and believe
for those of you watching you can
subscribe to the channel see more videos
like this click on the link in the
description to support me and leave a
comment let me know what you think I
love hearing from you thank you so much
I'll see you soon
you